إنهم يخططون لخطوتهم التالية في
المواجهة الأخيرة مع
بقايا قائد داعش الأخير جافيل سمكو ، حيث
تقود القوى الديمقراطية السورية
رجاله
في عملية ليلية أشعل تقدمهم قذائف
في آخر معقل لما
يسمى بالدولة الإسلامية.
تم تقليصها الآن إلى
قطعة أرض نائية ومتقلصة باستمرار على طول
نهر الفرات في شرق سوريا
في البداية ، بدأت طائرات التحالف الخفيفة
في الترابط
بينما تغامر القوات بدخول بلدة سوزا
أو
قد يستغرق ما تبقى منها وقتًا أطول من أن داعش ليست كذلك
إعطاء الأرض بسهولة ،
لم يمنعهم نيران المدافع الرشاشة الثقيلة من إيقافهم ،
فقد اضطرت القوات إلى التراجع
بحلول نهاية اليوم ، ووصلت التعزيزات
وعادوا للهجوم
ليس بدون تكلفة ،
في اليوم التالي ، بدأ بقصف بقذائف الهاون
على بلدة مارشتا المجاورة.
الهدف
على أطراف المدينة ، يحمل جندي
طفلًا تتبعه العائلة ،
لكن الجنود قلقون من أن هذه
القرى الأخيرة مليئة بمؤيدي تنظيم الدولة الأكثر
تشددًا  يتم التعامل
مع الجميع بشك ،
حيث يأمرون الشباب بخلع
قمصانهم لإظهار أنهم لا
يخفون أسلحة أو متفجرات
، الوجهة التالية لهذه العائلة ، واحدة من
العديد من المخيمات الموجودة في الصحراء والتي
تمتلئ بعشرات الآلاف
الذين فروا من القتال
أولئك الذين  تحدى تنظيم داعش دفع الثمن النهائي
تحت هذه البطانيات التي يقول الجنود
إن ثمانية
أطفال وامرأتين قُتلوا أثناء محاولتهم
الهروب
من الصور المروعة للغاية لإظهار
أن مقاتلي داعش هربوا تاركين
وراءهم أسلحة وذخيرة
ومع ذلك احتدمت المعركة على
آخر معارك لداعش.
سيهبط آخر معقله في سيل من
النار والدم بن ويتمان سي إن إن
بيروت